Johnny I would love to have the footage
of their pitch to Billy to convince him
and their pitch to me because their dad
they were different completely different
very different
I think at one point it kind of clicked
like this is not going away you know
this is it's actually evolving the
ability for everyone to be able to talk
and spread their voice really is where
it amped up to that other level and then
whoever that person was it was like you
know it was that cake legal maybe
Johnny's really the karate you know
maybe justice for Johnny that guy got a
raw deal and that that lent itself and
set the stage for the Cobra Kai fanbase
the series Cobra Kai fanbase coming to
the table all amped up for decades of
discussion and and it's kind of cool
that it all collided in such a good big
way it was a really close match but do
you want to get technical I kicked his
face it was an illegal kid Josh healed
John heartless Hayden Schlossberg the
crate is a copic I they emailed me and
they said we're having lunch and talk to
you about a project that we're excited
about so I said okay and then it was
just spit fire like the three-headed
dragon just a machine gun of information
like okay so here it is we're huge fans
of credit kids we love your work we want
to do this it's called Cobra Kai we got
the rights to Karate Kid you're Johnny
Lord be the anti-hero you're you know I
was like what you know I said you can't
just go do this you know like I never
could imagine getting the rights to do
Johnny Lawrence again and after the
Karate Kid that Jaden Smith came out I
felt like it was really all over like
okay that's moved on you know and I said
what's the next what's the next step
they said well we have to go convince
Ralph Macchio I said okay they led off
we're talking about the themes they were
very you know focused I could tell they
were nervous but the hayden was that he
started right away it says bullying like
it didn't start off saying we want to do
the Johnny Lawrence story about Cobra
Kai and and make him the hero of the
story to credit them they were also very
well-versed in what they wanted to do my
biggest question was they were pitching
it as a comedy I said well where's the
funny what's the tone that was the main
question and where's the Miyagi
isms and how is that going to be woven
into it I need for it to have balance if
you will across the board of The Karate
Kid universe second rule of Miyagi
garage fast but I believe that they were
the guys they wanted to make the show
the fans wanted to see because they
warned those kids welcome to Cobra Kai
some things never changed listen we're
not making the show without Pat Morita
performance is mr. Miyagi because that's
what elevated that one of the things
that elevated that film to what it is
today and then they're big shoes to fill
I mean Lou Russo has a line like that
early in the season - he looks at a
picture of me I said boy I got big shoes
to fill and he does and he learns very
soon just cuz you have knowledge of a
subject doesn't necessarily mean you
could teach it and mr. Miyagi was a
magical type character who had a special
touch and Lou Russo is learning that he
may not have that for he has to find his
own they've rebuilt the the Miyagi house
and the backyard and it's a big it's a
big set piece and certainly throughout
the second season and you know the day
one of shooting there was very nostalgic
for me and quite emotional because years
have gone by and that's not my life
anymore and but yet it's a part of who I
am and now I'm the old guy trying to
shed light on the young and the young
students you know it's it's kind of it's
warm and wonderful and and bittersweet
you know Pat would love this I mean we
miss him his daughter came to visit one
day surprise me on set we were doing a
scene in episode 4 of season 2 and it
was a scene that had a little Miyagi
magic element to it and his daughter
Ally came on the set and it's we took a
picture together I put it on Instagram
probably has the most views of anything
ever put up and it was nice it was nice
to share that moment
for life understand
yeah I mean the way we went into it was
this kind of dysfunctional father-son
relationship mentor student but now
Johnny's not a kid anymore he's a sensei
so it was more seeing eye to eye toe to
toe and that first moment when he walks
into the dojo in a similar way with
Ralph and I when he walked into the dojo
is a different type of electricity that
happened and it's he's Avoca call this
negative emotion out of me and he's the
guy that tried to kill me in the parking
lot and he's you know he trained me all
these things there's a lot of conflict
going on in Johnny and there there he is
you know though you know really the king
cobra stepping into the to Johnny's
Cobra Kai there's a lot going on it's
it's an emotional fight it's not just a
physical but now they see that the real
story is only just begun
how do you do this without alienating
all the other people oh we have some
Easter eggs in this season I can say
that much yeah there are some real nice
surprises in cameos yeah I mean the guys
the creator's always say there's you
know there's a whole canon of karate
kid' that could be drawn from for any
time so you know listen whoever
whoever's right for the moment that's
honest in this show we're excited about
and you know I was excited for as long
as it works organically into the story
and season one we had
Randy Heller who plays you know Lou
Russo's mom wonderful to have her back
and is a big embrace from the fans that
see that you know and there are some
others in season two and and beyond we
hope I heard you beat up a bunch of
teenagers in that parking lot out there
Oh dad
no I didn't beat up any teenagers
I kicked the [ __ ] out of a bunch of
[ __ ] who deserved it our first scene
together still one of my favorites in
the Cobra Kai series when he walked into
the dojo and I'm in the back you know I
mean we hadn't done this for 35 some
years now right and all of a sudden he
walks in and it was just wow Johnny
Lawrence calling someone else an [ __ ]
that's rich man yeah what's that
supposed to mean
it was just on and everything else was
gone and it was these two characters
exist again in this setting we walked
away like wow there's something really
yeah there's something really that
happened yeah yeah it's really it's a
little stare down and they question each
other and it just sets up the entire
series get your house in order LaRussa
the hell you think you're talking to me
that scene was magic man it was just you
know we worked together in the film
30-plus years ago and we've been friends
for years but that level of chemistry
that we had I didn't know that it was
there at the level that it's now turned
out to be I'm proud of it I mean it was
that you know we looked at each other
there's a little bit a little bit less
hair down here and a little bit more
wrinkles around here but it was like
yesterday you want to finish this bring
it on